you gonna give me the speech now what
speech I should calm down for where
Oregon no there's a guy in my trunk
delightful weird you know we at et
you've always thought of you as a
superhero and now you get to dress up
like one let's talk about this costume I
know what was your reaction the first
time you put it on did you have any
special requests for it like take me
down the whole path well I mean it's
this costume went through a lot of
iterations it did what we landed on
there were a lot of different things
that that we went through to get there
and it's just a combination of ideas
from our wardrobe designer Sharon Davies
and Damon making changes that weren't
originally the idea but I will tell you
this when Damon sent me the pilot script
there was an envelope tucked in a
certain page so I you know like anybody
I just went to that page and so on the
envelope said Regina do not open this
until you get to this page don't cheat
makes me want to cheat but I didn't so
then so I read it I was like I can't
wait to get to this page I can't win I
get to the page and it's the page that
introduces sister night and to open the
envelope and it was an artist's
rendering of me in the costume and it
was just I got chills and I think I got
a little teary eyed I think I may have
may or may not have and just was like
wow
first I wait till I'm almost 50 to be a
superhero just a hey I'm not gonna
question the universe and then I thought
wow Damon really trusts me hmm and we
just went from there with sending videos
to Nicole as I would do different
fittings
- Damon and he landed was discerning bad
ass costume yes yes like what I sent my
son the picture he was like yo ma so I'm
like I'm officially a cool mom yeah well
costume Thanks these first two episodes
really set the stage for Regina's
character Angela and her kick butt debut
what was your goal as a director when it
came to showcasing Regina's entrance
into the iconic world of Watchmen that's
an easy question honestly I always the
stories there the the you know we have
the script to me it's also I think what
I bring to things is really grounded in
reality and you know and starting with
Angela it was like who is she
you know she's born in Vietnam she's
here in the classroom playing the part
of mom and I you know to me that is a
performance more than almost maybe
sister night and we had a great
discussion of the glasses and it's our
first time meeting our lead like 15 to
20 minutes into the pilot and taking off
the glasses was I thought a really
hilarious way of paying saying this is
our superhero this is our Clark Kent
you know Regina King and then the sister
night of it all just again it's all it
to me it's character and grounding it
but also the reveal and just that car
and the the the lair where she's doing
the D like you know it's our version of
the Batcave and how the costume works
and it's a weird costume we have a
rosary and the badge you know and all
these things and then you know just that
skirt was delicious to sweep and follow
so just going for reveal and making it
as awesome and energetic and I think
this is so exciting about you know don't
go into that whole process with Vicki is
that there were so many little details
and it takes time it's a different setup
for one quick you know like three
seconds and I feel like if this
opportunity had come to me before I
started directing I
I would have lost my mind like oh my god
we're doing it again what didn't we just
do that last episode but as being close
to Nikki and also having the wonderful
opportunity to have worked as a director
I can understand even though even every
moment was tedious I could see what was
happening and then just to actually
watch it all come together which is kind
of like because it's the audience has no
idea how many people will go into just a
small little moment and it's pretty
fantastic what was it like getting into
fighting shape for this role well I'm
always in shape I'm always in shape I'm
never not in shape so that we didn't
have to go through this rigorous
preparation to get my body in place to
wear something that is going to show
every little everything my costume is
not the costume has the built-in apps so
[Laughter]
require you know someone to already be
fit but we have we have an amazing stunt
coordinator Justin who we worked with
him on leftovers and he already knew my
ability from when we worked together on
leftovers and I have an amazing stunt
double which this is the first time I've
worked with her I actually was very very
like Nicole and I had like conversations
I was like you've got to find someone
who's I don't want anyone to ever think
it's not me so it took a while to find
sadhika someone who had the ability but
also was built like me and so once
Justin learned her strengths he just
coordinated sequences that
to both of our strengths so we could
just move in and out seamlessly